In a para virtualized setting on the other hand the operating system knows that
its physical memory is not contiguous. And
there for this burden of efficient mapping
can be shifted into the guest operating
system itself. So now the guest operating
system is going to maintain. Contiguous physical
memory makes it simpler in terms of
all the other subsystems to do that. But it is also going to know that its
notion of physical memory, is not the same as machine memory, and so it will map
the discontiguous physical memory to real hardware
pages. So that burden of doing the PPN
to MPN mapping can be pushed into the
guest operating system in a very virtualized setting.
So on an architecture like Intel, where the page table is a data
structure of the operating system. And it is also used by the hardware to do
the address translation. The responsibility of allocating
and managing the hardware page table data
structure can be shifted into the guest
operating system. In a fully virtualized setting,
it's not possible to do that because the
operating system in a fully virtualized setting is
unaware of the fact that it is not
running on bare metal. But in a paravirtualized
setting, since it is possible to do that,
it is more efficient to push this efficient
mapping handling into the guest operating system. For
example, in Xen, which is a paravirtualized hypervisor
it provides a set of Hypercalls for the guest operating system to tell the
Hypervisor about changes to the hardware page
table. So, for instance, there is a call
that says create page table and this allows a guest operating system to allocate
and initialize a page frame that it
has previously acquired a real page frame that
it is previously acquired from the hypervisor as a hardware resource. It can
target that physical page frame as a page table data structure. Recall that
each guest operating system, would have gotten a bunch of physical memory from
the hypervisor at the beginning of
establishing its foot print on the hypervisor.
And so it can use one of those real physical memories to host a pay stable
data structure, on behalf of a new process
that it launches now. So anytime a new process
starts up in the guest operating system, the
guest operating system will make a hypercall to xen
saying. Please create a page table for me,
and this is the page frame that I'm giving
you to use as the page table. So, when the guest operating system has to operate
this particular process which got launched, then it
can make another hypercall to the hypervisor saying
please switch to page table, and here is
the location of the page table. The hypervisor
doesn't know about all these processes. All it
understands is that there's a hypercall that says change
the page table from whatever it used to be to this new page table. And
that essentially results in this guest operating system,
switching the address space. Of the currently running
process on the the bare hardware on the bare metal to P1 by this switch page
table hypercall. Xen will do that appropriate thing,
of setting the hardware register of the processor
to point to this page table data structure.
In response to this hypercall from the guest operating
system. If the process P1 one were to page
fault at some point of time, the page fault
would be handled by the guest operating system. We'll
talk about how it does that later on. But
once it handles that page fault for P1 and
says, oh, this particular virtual page of this process
is now going to correspond to a physical frame that I own. I'm going to tell the
hypervisor that the mapping in the page table, has to be set for
this translation that I just established for
the faulted page for this process. So
there's another hypercall that's available for updating
a given page table data structure. And using
this the guest operating system can deal
with modifications to the base table data structure.
All the things that an operating system would have to do in a normal setting on
bare metal. You have to be able to do in the setting where you have the
hypervisor sitting between the real hardware and the
guest operating system. And the three things that
are required to be done in the conflicts of
memory management, in a para virtualized setting, is being able
to create a brand new hardware address space for
a newly launched process which involves creating a page table.
That's a hypercall that's available. When you do a
conflict switch, you want to switch the page table. That's a
hypercall that's available when you do a conflict switch in
the guest operating system from P1 to P2, the guest
can tell the hypervisor that the page table to use from now on is such and so.
That's the way the guest can do a contact
switch from one process to another. And, thirdly, since
not all of the address space or the
memory footprint of a process would be physical memory,
if the currently running process were to incur at
page four, that has to be handled by the
guest operating system. In handling that, it
establishes a mapping between the messy virtual page
for this process and the physical frame in which the contents of the page is
now contained. That mapping has been put
into the page table for this particular process.
Again that's something that only the hypervisor can
do, because it is a privileged operation happening
inside the hardware. And for that purpose, the
hypervisor provides a hyper call that allows a
guest operating system to update the base table
data structure. So at the outset I said that
handling virtual memory is a thorny issue. Doing
the mapping from virtual to physical on every
memory access, with all the intervention of the
guest operating system is the key to good performance.
And it can be done both in fully virtualized and
paravirtualized setting by the tricks that we talked about just now.